time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week nearly two
months ago President Trump declared the
opioid crisis a public health emergency
one component is over prescribing of
drugs and that was the subject of
research at the University of Michigan
doctors surveyed 170 patients who
underwent gallbladder removal surgery
asking about their post-surgery opioid
use they then use the information to
craft custom post-op prescribing
guidelines and then applied these
guidelines to a subsequent group of
patients undergoing the same surgery to
examine differences in opioid use here
to discuss the findings is CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus who
joins us from Los Angeles bright and
early David good morning morning Anthony
thanks for being with us so what were
the changes implemented and how does it
affect the prescribing of opioids it's
such a cool study because it's so low
tech they basically questioned these
patients and these patients were given
on average 50 pills of opioids and they
actually only use six so they custom you
know for the surgery for gallbladder
sure they went down and give them 15
pills and then they only use four so
when you give somebody 50 pills and they
use six there's a lot of excess oil out
there and the potential for abuse or
addiction is there so this relatively
low-tech
thinking about what they're doing way
actually made a big impact doc it's a
relatively small study are we gonna need
to see more of these as we try and
determine the best prescription
strategies I think it's you know me as a
doc I just write a number I don't really
think how many do they use so
data-driven prescriptions are really the
way we have to go so I love this they
did it for one surgery gallbladder
surgery we need to do this with more and
actually have real data on how many
pills to give patients all right up next
a new cancer test that could help
doctors and patients make more informed
decisions the tests can detect genetic
mutations in tumors and was approved by
the Food and Drug Administration just
last week in a press release FDA
Commissioner Scott Gottlieb said in part
quote by leveraging two policy efforts
aimed at expediting access to promising
new technologies we've been able to
bring fat pate
patience faster access to a breakthrough
diagnostic that can help doctors tailor
cancer treatments dr. agus what was the
test that was approved and what's the
potential here so this is DNA sequencing
so what this means is that every patient
now with a cancer can have their tumor
DNA sequence so we can identify what are
the on and the off switches and it can
enable us to use certain drugs that
target those genetic mutations so this
really is the new era of personalized
medicine we've been doing it but it
hasn't yet been approved by the FDA and
now Medicare at the same time the same
day said we're gonna cover it for our
patients mmm David in their press
release the FDA said that it will detect
an extensive number of cancer biomarkers
what exactly is a cancer biomarker so a
cancer biomarker is something that tells
you about the fundamentals of the cancer
either how to treat it or what's
happening with the cancer in this case
the biomarker are about 300 plus genes
where we can look at them and see if
they're altered or mutated and if
they're turned on we could target them
dr. agus the FDA Commissioner Scott
Gottlieb mentioned that this was part of
a sort of expedited fast-track process
to get this approved are we gonna see
more of that in the future oh yeah we're
gonna see a lot more of these newer
technologies approved and in record time
and at the same time I think what's
novel here is that Medicare CMS said at
the same time we're gonna cover it for
our patients so both of those happening
at the same time it's fantastic it's the
perfect storm to benefit patients with
cancer all right finally an eye towards
the future a team of scientists and
engineers at the University of Southern
California has developed what could be a
revolutionary treatment for eye injuries
in a study published this week in
Science Translational Medicine
researchers showed off a glue-like
material that can temporarily seal eye
injuries until more advanced medical
treatment is available the sealant is
temperature sensitive and morphs from a
fluid to a semi solid when applied to
the eye it can then be safely removed
with cold water the hope is that the
technique could be used by medics on the
battlefield and in
they're situations where full medical
care isn't close at hand doc this is so
cool
that's a medical term could you see
applications other we're beyond
optometry oh yeah this is wild I mean I
love that it's done at University of
Southern California where I am but it's
a polymer that when you cool it it
becomes liquid and it's like water but
then you put it on something on the body
in this case the eye and at 98 degrees
it starts to become a solid so in the
case of eye injuries it allows the eye
to be stabilized so you can get into a
hospital but you can conceivably do this
in bleeding wounds or elsewhere we're in
the field or in a community where you
don't have accessible to great surgeons
who could do these minor or micro
procedures you can actually take care of
patients so very exciting Wow and it's
like glue how often dr. David agus
always good to see you thank you for
getting up so very early thank you guys